you know a lot of a lot of ambulance
ambulance drivers is gay men and that's
good it's good you know it's everyone
should be able to do whatever job right
but what I'm saying is this a lot of
ambulance drivers is gay men and the
reason is because they're thinking oh
I'm gonna pick up it's a way to meet
another man they think oh you know I'm
gonna pick up a man he's sick I will I'm
gonna be part of the thing that makes
him well and it's because a lot of time
men get hurt you know 60 out of 70
people that get hurt or probably men
overall and the thing about that is that
a lot of men you think you know call ten
of your friends right now ask them if
they're hurt men call ten men friends
and say are you hurt see how many say
fine ten that say no call him in a week
I guarantee you for them are hurt and
that's so that's just you know that's
just a bit of how it works how it goes
but um but yeah gay man they're a lot of
times they're skirting around in that
ambulance
you know because think about an Ambo
it's got the tune just got the lights I
mean it's got dope in the bag dude
that's a frickin you know that's really
a just a gay Greyhound really and it's a
nice way of but it's really a way where
a lot of a lot of men who love other men
will meet straight men sometimes because
they come pick you up oh you're hurt get
in here get in the back you know they'll
be taking your blood pressure and
they'll be like oh don't they'll slip
there they'll slip their phone number in
there like oh your blood pressure it's a
it's ninety over nine eight five six one
one two four
7/7 Darren and you're like what what is
my blood pressures is doing a lot and
while they're driving they'll sometimes
will say you know oh maybe all these
women making you sick and you're like
why I just you know I was I was getting
a frit I fell off the roof I was getting
a frisbee I don't this I don't know and
they're like oh yeah maybe these women
they throwing frisbees up there to get
you hurt and you're like damn they'll
put an IV in your arm and put and slip
their number in your pocket same time oh
let me give you 200 cc's of that and uh
seven digits of that yeah I was in a
I've been in a car accident and the
ambulance man came first of all his name
Virgil right and he picked me up and
then he tried the Heimlich maneuver on
me probably five times and I've been in
a car accident so finally I'm like dude
what is it what how what are you even
going on here he said I just wanted to
make sure your Airways were clear I said
I just want to make sure we're clear
that I want to go to the hospital man
I'm not trying to meet somebody right
now so anyway today's episode let's get
into some of this man we got we got some
stuff today's episode is brought to you
by skill share and look I've had skills
in my life and their skills I haven't
had you know I've always wanted to do
different types of skills grenadier e
doing grenades painting large painting
buildings buildings or painting large
football field areas of cement sides of
boats painting something big different
skills a lot of things learning how to
ooh do looking for a gold looking for
precious metals there's a lot of
different skills that I would like to
have skills share is an online learning
community for creators creators with
more than 25,000 classes in business
design and more you'll discover
countless ways to make your curiosity
fire inside of you because curiosity is
a um it's a gun powder and you need
something to strike it and that is what
Skillshare does you can take classes in
mobile photography creative writing even
illustration if you're looking to
discover a new passion or start a side
hustle or gain decent skills that are
professional skills share is there to
keep you learning thriving and reaching
your new goals join the millions of
students already learning on Skillshare
today you can even take classes like
low-budget filmmaking you're not gonna
make a blockbuster if you can't make a
just a regular bus tour first so you got
to start small get two months of
Skillshare for free that's right
Skillshare is offering tpw listeners two
months of unlimited access to over
25,000 classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo von again go to Skillshare
comm slash Theo von to start your two
months now Skillshare comm slash Theo
von oh it's a special day in my life
today I hope it's a special day in your
life today and I'm sure it is for some
reason hey bro is heaven
not much man what you up to ready to do
a little bit of work a little TV just
about it put the kids upstairs relax and
watch TV in their bed oh nice dear
not much man uh just wanted to wish you
happy birthday
appreciate it 42 are you really yeah Wow
no no you've been alive man no life is
over then what are you gonna do I don't
know don't call an ambulance do one of
my buddies told me that a lot of gay men
are driving ambulances to meet other men
how crazy is that
yeah hey I'll do it Larry takes how was
the birthday good yeah yeah we went to
church this morning then it up and
basically watching a lot of football
today what here came over oh nice kids
were here and it was good it was nice
oh yeah now I gotta get back to work
tomorrow though yeah yeah Ashley sent me
those pictures man was pretty nice oh
yeah yeah yeah we keep my bruise it went
pretty good you know oh that's good
anyway well thanks for calling me
everything yeah man dude happy birthday
bro you know I love you man I know uh
you not talk a lot and I just want to
let you know that I love you you know I
think I'm proud of you man I'm so proud
of you appreciate love you too Jessie
texts me Anna
I felt bad when we left that you know
real all going home to our families and
dealers getting on a slot machine at
11:00 a.m. I felt like maybe he was
feeling lonely or maybe he gets lonely
and I said yeah probably I think he does
sometimes and he said well if y'all talk
much and say family talk sometimes bolts
were trialing the day I said so we're
actually even though we're not around
each other you're not a really close and
he's my best friends and I feel better I
was out there by yourself you know yeah
dang it does sound sad when you see it
like that when you hear it like that at
what that perspective yes but yeah
where the actual information that Rhino
that we talked almost every day yeah oh
yeah totally made sweet that he cared
yeah it was a president nice intimate
but um it made me feel good to be able
to say to him hey no he's done it alone
you know he's got me yeah pretty cool
yeah thanks man yeah I love having you
dude
you know I'm excited about uh you know
you definitely brothers yeah
just it makes it easier when you got
somebody but now I know I'll appreciate
it appreciate you in there for me you
know yeah dude you're doing a great job
huh so when did we can trade off - yeah
yeah hike man that's the name of that
guy you mean height we need that hype
man huh yeah I was telling us if I sell
even like a hype man I said I guess it's
great
maybe I could get Ashley or max to do it
awesome you've actually would love it
Zef you would too Mac seems like Nona
started over let's start it over some do
her paper boy he did not have worked I
know it I think he likes to be gloves
that'll is for you to listen to him I
think I talked to the money's rambling
on about how things are gonna go and was
the way impromptu additions oh that's
funny
they loves that it's loves you listen to
them and be involved in his headlong
he's put it out there hmm
is if he likes affection and recognition
I'm not sure West our life's a lie just
yet no I'm not pretty soon that's coming
right now like mommy yeah so alright bro
get a minute sweetie let's axe Twitty
Arizona caller
alright I will man happy birthday bro
alright thanks love you alright man love
you too
good luck bye bye that's my brother um
and he uh he was born today a long time
ago and not that
long ago but uh you know we and he and I
was our relationships become better over
the years and you know it's um yeah it's
just great I'm just you know I'm
grateful
I really am man and that's one thing you
know man I'm just happy to feel some
gratitude for a second you know I've
been I've just had a struggle feeling
that kind of stuff recently and uh and
just to just be on terms enough with my
brother to call him on his birthday and
let him know that I care about him you
know and I just hope he knows you know
how much I love him you know what and
how much uh how much of an inspiration
he is to me I think it's um it's funny
sometimes I don't know if people know
can really tell what they mean to others
you know it's like sometimes people will
just you know people won't be able to
tell like you can never really fully
kind of Express to somebody how they
affect you sometimes maybe you can maybe
I just haven't tried that much you know
maybe I haven't or maybe I have you know
I don't know just kind of spitballing
here but I'm just how I'm happy that my
brother was born even though we weren't
close for a long time I'm happy that you
know I got a surprise as I've gotten
older and and and that's been the gift
of uh of his you know pretty
unconditional love really and he loves
his kids and just he loves to just care
he yeah I don't know he's just he is
he's a deep dude man that dude is bruh i
dude he should have a diving board right
next to him I wouldn't be surprising my
brother rolled around and had a diving
board next to him because that dude is a
deep he's a deep dude and he loves it he
loves to know what makes people think
and feel and
and uh he's just really really
fascinated by that kind of stuff and and
it brushes off into me and it's there
when I need it and he's such a great
reference and uh you know and a lot of
times he's don't he he he's almost like
a father to me too in some ways you know
it's interesting how we get different
pieces of what we need from different
places or I do you know I get different
uh you know and sometimes I think I
don't you know one of the reasons maybe
why I'm not like in like successful
relationships or some of that kind of
thing is because I I want to get the
attention that I need I want to get it
from I want to get it how I want it I
want to get it it's almost like maybe I
like okay I'll get I'll get this from
here and this from this person and this
from this person not in a selfish way
but just this is where I will let these
things up hit me you know I'll let this
person care about me and that will
suffice for this feeling that I need and
I'll let just just because it's more in
control you know it's almost like I get
you know I get it's almost like I want
to I want to control where I'll let
affection into my life so that and it's
such a tricky path that I let it in
through that it's but at least that way
I know that the most protected you know
I'm the most safe for myself anyway I
didn't mean to get off on a on that you
know on the dam on the dam uh you know
whatever then you know I didn't mean to
ding you know pour a couple quarts of
motor in the old heart engine but but
you know my brother was born and I'm and
I'm grateful for that and uh and shout
out to all the brothers out there a lot
of brothers come to my show
and come out to the shows and and it's
great man when I see two brothers
together just like it's just a special
thing it's like finding a seashell and a
damn [ __ ] and uh you know in a in a
wave pool and like a shitty wave pool at
a place off the interstate
[Music]
come on let's celebrate we get we gonna
do it we can do it
[Music]
celebrate man
[Music]
[Music]
we celebrate
celebrate all your pain
celebrate all your pains baby I don't
know about that one didn't get me really
nothing really didn't get me if it's
getting somebody I'm not that person
let me think about something that really
could give me I'm a kind of guy that can
be gotten and you know if I'm an
ambulance and I come pick you up you
know what I'm gonna be rocking Racha my
don't be filling your fuzz holes with
this hitter
from a mile away
[Music]
since with another man so soon
we approach to a reality
that fire hose
don't let miss Pam Colin
and there you go and we are here and we
are alive we are alive and we are going
to do our best thank you guys for being
here today and I hope that your life is
a just a real sack of joy I hope if the
cops pull you over dude and they frisk
your pockets you got a bunch of [ __ ]
joy sausages in them and you just pull
out a couple links in a couple Paddy's
boy and treat that off at her officer to
some breakfast because I hope you just
full of damn joy meats today here in
September 8th 2019 September 9 it will
be when you hear this oh I didn't what
I'm upset about the fight
so people saw the fight I'm not upset I
mean I'm man I David I was just gone
dude I wanted you just kept me nobody
could beat that man khabib it's not he's
not it's like fighting lava it's like
fighting like it's almost like khabib is
like one of those blankets you see on
the Internet where it's like oh you need
this heavy this heavy blanket oh you
can't sleep here here's this heavy
blanket for a hundred and forty dollars
you can get this 30 pound blanket they
said I don't like it that is a trap that
is a trap dude somebody right now people
are like oh yeah they've been they got
the new blanket and they've been asleep
for a month yeah the baby's been resting
for two weeks the baby can't get out the
bed because he's under a dang 30 pound
blanket and that's I just felt like I
don't know man let's let's take a couple
of calls about it some people came in
and you guys know that we're cheering
for dust in the diamond Poirier and he's
that rare element I mean he should be on
the periodic table
and I think one day he maybe let's get
into a couple of calls that came in on
the hotline as always the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three gang gang what up Co I'm just
sitting here heartbroken I wonder how
you're feeling right now Dustin Poirier
just took that loss
what do you feeling there's no man from
doubt man and I'll tell you this we got
so many calls expressed and uh just
people sharing their moods during the
fight and what was going on what my
thoughts uh I mean the fight itself I
thought you look first of all I don't
know anything about fighting okay I'm
not gonna pretend like I do I don't know
you know I think Dustin is a very neat
person and I think he's very dynamic as
a human and so I want to see him do well
at whatever he's doing you know like my
investment personally is in him as a
human he happens to be a fighter he's
any any great fighter I just think you
know like khabib or khabib or however is
uh he's like kind of like I'm to me it's
not fight it would be neat if they had
to be on their feet for half the round
and they could then the rest there's
only a certain amount of time they could
be on the ground now I'm not in and I
told Brendan Schaub that and he goes
well that's not the sport and and that
you may be right but for me as a viewer
I'd like to see a little bit cuz I want
to see both of them be able to do some
of the stuff that I really you know that
I like to watch them do I like to I like
to see the action at different levels so
you know that should kind of bum me out
cause Covey V is [ __ ] boring the [ __ ]
is boring dude it's like watching
somebody lose their house to some lava
takes you know 19 minutes or whatever
and it's [ __ ] boring so yeah go watch
lava do get on the internet they got a
bunch of lava
flows did I used to watch float man you
could you could be on a three-hour
youtube of a flow bruh and it finally
[ __ ] kills a sapling outside of Kauai
and you're like oh [ __ ] man
it was three hours of my life thankfully
I had a little bit of cocaine you feel
me boy
[Laughter]
that'll make the lava speed up a little
bit but that it was like yeah it was
like watching some I mean it just I
don't know and no disrespect that guy's
great it at what he does just to me it's
[ __ ] boring to me is boring you know
I'm gonna do you know I watch what I
watch you know and I like to consume
things how I likened to me this [ __ ] was
boring and I just you know I was just
bummed man I mean I was really bummed
out and there's people you know at the
bar yelling [ __ ] and and uhm and I
watched it with Nick and Jionni
you know the premature and the twink man
that you know our crew we watched it
together as a team and and we were I
mean the first the the venue looked like
a like a damn no air conditioning you're
like where are these guys in a tent out
back and I'm not saying that they just
when I was watching the on the on the
fight pass they got this couch from it
you can buy and you get that you know
special deal on the internet and you can
watch it and it looked like they were in
a damn FEMA tent or something out back
so but hey you supposed to you know they
can fight wherever it's just the the the
live stream or whatever they had was
going was it was vit was very boring the
atmosphere seemed kind of mild and what
else but yeah I mean I was definitely
bummed I was bummed for always bumper
him you know I wanted him to be able to
win I know how much he really wanted to
win and it was very evident when you
watch his you know his interviews
afterwards and stuff and
and let's get a little bit we got this
call I'll share a little bit more on my
thoughts we got this call that came in a
perspective from the arena here we go
hey field what's going on this is ally
and Dubai
hey Ally thank you for calling man and
uh you know and thank you guys for
hosting that event it seemed like and
even Dustin said it was just an amazing
event and if you watch on um on Dustin's
story on his Instagram story they have
the dudes eatin gold meat and they're
doing all kind of crazy stuff over there
so really seeing his experience over
there is is pretty cool just to see a
guy from just a small place in Louisiana
to get to go on that adventure that's a
small victory right there let's hear
more Ali I just thought I'd call in and
give you some perspective on how things
went inside the arena last night since
you weren't able to make it yeah it was
hot in there that's the first thing and
there was about a hundred thousand
Russians in the arena Wow and dude if I
see two Russians at a gas station I'm
driving off usually because those guys
do don't drink dude they'll sit there to
put don't have look they'll be mixing
use they use diesel as a mixer so you'll
see a guy with our orange juice and uh
you know in 96 petrol you know their
diesel enough you'll see a guy at the
Exxon [ __ ] Mick making a picture of
mixed drinks those are some there's some
tough guys let's hear more that's out
like so the boy Dustin was definitely
some hostile territory and they were
amped up all night every fight seemed
like I had a Russian guy in it just
different sizes you know one guy's like
300 pounds one guy's like a hundred
pounds but they all look kind of the
same yeah I felt like they kept taking
one guy in the back and then pulling a
hair you know stuff and Fanning him or
pulling air on him or putting muscle in
him or just like they were back there
Frankenstein you know they got a table
they got 19 things they got a beard
sideburns no beard you know more fat
more muscle here's some sternum
boom boom boom send him back out same
guy more and the crowd was getting amped
up
there was about three more fights just
in our section so it's a crazy
environment and obviously you didn't get
the result you wanted but I just thought
it you don't give you a perspective from
in there he definitely you know he
didn't win the fight but he definitely
won a lot of people over and he's got a
lot of respect from the people in the
crowd and I think people all over the
world now know who he is and what he
stands for
and that's something that he can take
with him for the rest of his life you
know the mighty championship belts come
and go but that respect he had and you
know kind of putting Louisiana on the
map too he can hold his head high for
that so anyway all right Thank You Ellie
I really appreciate that you know I love
that on the ground that just that lie
you know Thank You bruh that's really
kind of you to share what that
experience was like from there you know
really you know and and and and just the
fact that yeah you're right he can hold
his head up high that's something that
yeah like uh
I was bummed that you know I was
definitely upset that he came in second
place I don't see how anybody beats
khabib it's kind of like when Michael
Jordan played you just but still it just
because you didn't beat Michael Jordan
doesn't mean you're not Dominique
Wilkins you know I mean Dustin is still
beat ever he's if it's anybody else if
it's any other time existence in the
universe you know he's a he got half the
belt you know he got the belt when it
wasn't available it could be he was he's
he's the pinnacle there's just there's
this other pinnacle that's floating off
in the distance that that's its own it's
on its own frequency and that is uh and
that's Kebede but I uh yeah I think
something about Dustin is I feel like he
- he pie doesn't even realize and he may
man this is I'm probably I don't know
from being judgmental here or or hopeful
I feel like over his tenure as run you
know especially in the past year that
through through fighting and through UFC
he has shown who he is as a person and a
lot a lot of people even if they have a
great vehicle in their life that allows
them to achieve dreams our goals
aspirations rarely does also who they
are which is the bigger victory of them
being just a just uh you know a good
person of them fighting the good fight I
mean that's what his foundation is
called but yeah fighting the good fight
I think a lot of people realized oh I'm
a fan of this guy because of who he is
yes he's a fighter but but he's I think
he's like a hero to a lot of people and
I know it's a kind of a wild word but
yeah I mean I guess he's definitely an
inspiration and so I think yeah it's
like I just hope that he sees I think
that he kind of transcended the sport a
little bit in the sense that he has
gotten that people see him as a as a
communicator and as a interpreter for
good in the world and that you know uh I
don't know I just you know some few
athletes get to do that few people in
their in their genres of entertainment
or of competition get to do that where
you also see their heart you see who
they are and then that becomes like I
could see Dustin being a mayor or a
governor even like I think he just has
this you know he has this relentless
drive that is going to bring him success
in anything he does but I just you know
you know I don't know Here I am pie like
[ __ ] they sound like I don't even know
you know I just think he's and he's such
an inspiration to a lot of people and
yeah he'll have the head
the belly he'll have the belt you know
he might get different belts but I think
he's in this bigger competition I think
where people see oh that guy you know a
lot of Fighters they come and go but
this guy can stay forever if he wants to
as a leader of people and and I just
hope he sees that I hope he sees but I
hope you I hope he sees what we can all
see that he's in this bigger competition
of of inspiring people that and of kind
of like of competing on a higher level
of a human level that I think that we
all want to be in the ring you know we
all want to be in that ring enough that
makes sense but anyhow man but thanks
for that man that's really nice you
descend in that perspective and just to
have us to get an idea of what it was
like in there yeah I can't imagine being
in there but I thought it was great man
I was fun and watch him get out there
and perform it was fun to watch him to
me it all seemed like a performance too
but it was very fun to see the
excitement in there and people just you
know all the crazy beards and everybody
looking like they got pubic hair on them
everybody's cheeks looked like a set of
nuts up in there and they got a damn you
know everybody's wrapped up in the
turbans
what were the concessions like that's
what I would love to know that what the
concessions were like in there like at
the concession stand like do they have a
Pepsi do they have a dynamite what do
you know what are they what's for sale I
want to let you know this it's a new
season Antonio Brown is on the well he's
on the Patriots now can you believe that
makes you hate him and respect him at
the same time Le'Veon Bell is with the
Jets Odell Beckham is in Cleveland the
season has started there's so many new
great players mahomes blew it up the one
thing that hasn't changed is where I'm
putting my money down on all the games
my bookie is the place to bet on
football every weekend
my book he has better bonuses and more
prop bets than any other sports book
period this year they're hosting the
first online handicapping super contest
and first place in that deal is to win
at least one hundred thousand and it
only costs one hundred to enter so
that's that chance for that one hundred
all you have to do is pick five NFL
games against the spread every week to
climb the leaderboard and score your
share of the huge cash prize pool my
book he also has live in game betting on
every NFL game they've got the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and for you fantasy guys out there you
can even bet the over-under on how many
fantasy points a player will score each
game use promo code past to activate an
offer where you get up to one thousand
dollars first deposit bonus so you can
double your first deposit you put in a
thousand they'll match that's right use
promo code pas T to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's my B
oh okay ie and don't forget to use promo
code pas t when creating your account to
claim the bonus bet when get paid yeah I
think Dustin Poirier fights uh you know
when I was dealing I've said this before
I think but I couldn't you know I never
I was afraid to defend myself nobody
taught me how to defend myself and my
brother you know who is uh I mean he's
real he's really a lighthouse in my life
now but but we didn't have any you know
we couldn't we didn't have that we
didn't have the ability to defend
ourselves we didn't even have the
confidence to defend to try and defend
ourselves you know and we grew up in a
place and was a little scary and um and
it made things tough but the thing that
gets me I think that I feel like Dustin
Poirier fought fights for people that
can't fight for themselves you know I
feel like he's part of this bigger fight
and that's the thing that I see about
him that um you know that I hope he that
he can read that he
recognises about himself you know he's
inspirational he loves his family he's
connected you know to a higher power and
uh and he's just he's fighting the good
fight
you know he's fighting the good fight
and um and in today's environment
especially with athletes you know you
see these other guys egomaniacs and they
don't want to do this and they don't
want to do that and dustin takes they
sent him out there to the desert man
what are they you know and he took it
like a man who said I'll go that's what
that's you know that's net that's the
next part of my life that's the next
moment and I think if he chooses to
continue I think he'll have many more
opportunities but I you know and uh and
I hope you will I'd love to see him up a
couple more fellows ass out there but
I'm a fan for life man I'm a fan look if
that dude decided to run for mayor if he
decided to be hell if he decided to do a
cooking show or if he just decided to
start a damn pressure washing business
I'm in I'm in dude I bought in you know
I ain't got no jewelry bruh but you know
I let a little bit of money on the
diamond but I'll invest in a diamond
right there but thank you guys for those
calls man as always the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three you know oh some tour dates are
coming back on the books and I don't
know what those are those are some of
the october dates and I will announce
those on social media this week so
that's that's cool
I appreciate you guys's patience with
that and some of them may be the exact
date that was already there so they
won't change so scheduling sometimes you
know things happen this and that and
that's where we are all right let's get
into a little bit more of this episode
here you know and there's ambulances you
could I bet they're circling the block
right now because I'm looking fresh
today you ever get that vibe you leaving
out the house some days this happens to
me I'll probably once every maybe 2 or 3
weeks
I'll leave the house and I'm like damn
look out ladies
cuz they got a real beautiful [ __ ]
hitting the streets today you know and
I'll go right up and say hey hey madam
I'll say something right to a girl then
oh hey you know hey barb what's uh how
are you tonight you know what uh oh you
just have you been waiting for the bus
I'll say anything to a lady Oh what's up
Suzette oh dang huh
looks like you might have to tits under
your shirt I'll do that I'll be that
frisky biscuit baby you feel meets
breads breads breads breads baby cam mmm
that here's the call that came in right
here gang hey Co this is Dalton in Texas
and yet a gentleman call in studies a
machinist in the gunsmithing
he was going through some pretty hard
stuff but literally I was just watching
him in my truck I stopped the video just
so I could called I'm calling because
I've been there
ya don't appreciate that call man yeah
let's uh yeah he just called in last
week and he was a gunsmith yeah you've
been there homeward so you didn't leave
your name he left a message but talking
to you man you're uh you're gonna figure
it out that's that's what that's the
cool part is that none of this lasts
forever and you know something I always
tell my wife there's this excerpt from
the movie the Martian as cheesy as it is
but at the very end Matt Damon tells
this class or future astronauts he says
when you experience something and and
you have one problem you basically just
have to start put one problems on you
and you start and then you go on to the
next problem
going to the next problem and eventually
if you solve all your problems you get
to come home and it's just cheesy as it
is I try to apply that to everything
because like Theo says if you don't
start taking action if you don't start
putting one step in front of the other
nothing's going to come to fruition
and that's that's the shitty part man if
you just sit there and you start beating
yourself up about all this stuff but you
don't start stepping it won't get better
I think everybody I think everybody
believes in you man so uh good luck we
know you'll figure it out brother thank
you oh you bet man thank you that yeah I
think that's that's perfect suggestion
for that young man yeah you just have to
take action you know it's a man it's
hard sometimes isn't it it's hard to get
that get that gumption to function you
know it's hard when it feels like Oh or
when you're surprised oh this is what
life served me man I didn't expect this
I didn't expect this but it's hard
sometimes it's hard man but thank you
that's nice you to think of that that of
that of that young fella and they give
that call and I'm gonna check in with
him to this week and see how he's doing
let's take another call that came in
here nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three onward hey big brother
how you doing dog I wanted to call in
and say it's a moment of happiness to
happen in my life recently and it's the
little things that count it's kind of
ridiculous what it is the little things
that count man I've been having a pretty
shitty go at it after for a while now
having car troubles my wife got in an
accident going bad I only get my hours
on my job everything sucks and you know
my wife's you gotta go have some cheese
pulls and she's really worried about
that [ __ ] ingham she's getting the
molars that she's getting them teeth
pulled like a dad last Wow baby like a
wolf my neighbor he's devil wolf and
we're young and that thing must have
grown probably 600 teeth do it every two
weeks they be over there pulling teeth
out of it god I probably had in my
bedroom I bet I had 40 teeth in a little
you know you know on a little low plate
in my room homework and she's having a
real bad day the other day and so I'm
thinking to myself you know the little
things matters so instead of eating a
piece of [ __ ] dinner that we got if I
took her out to a favorite fast-food
place you know nothing fancy but like I
said little things and the thing that's
crazy is she loves the Wendy's name and
oh god I love Wendy's dude and my mother
and I used to go there sometime we'd be
out on the route and mom would pull over
there that Wendy's dude and god damn bro
I remember folding that they had that
foil there wrapping its foil also it's
got a little bit of metal on it I don't
know what it is aluminum or something
how you many of them and damn where I
remember just opening it and just that
warm hot [ __ ] just meaty bready
baking heat it was sitting right there
looking at me brought that little law
junior bacon cheeseburger boy from Big
Dave Thomas bra god damn well salute
Dave Thomas boy respect him did I would
vote for Dave Thomas dude 6,000 times
dude if I had 6,000 different forms of
legal legal and different citizenship
documentation Oh word
it's a woman right next to his [ __ ]
sucks the order is always wrong dude but
yesterday we go through suggests that
for for for special hmm my god bruh
dude don't make me come out though y'all
come from behind the counter and spend
some time with your wife as well do it
I'll yank a couple molars out of her
mouth to make room for myself you feel
me do because this is sign and damn
romantic Albert you're supposed to get
them for chicken nuggets they let you
upgrade to the spicy chicken nuggets or
throw them s ends baby then spicy nugs
and when I was young a nugget like you
you see like you saying it was a little
serving of chicken broth it was a little
you know a little [ __ ] sweet tender
[ __ ] serving of chicken here you go
boy that's a nugget because sometimes if
you were if you handed like cuz a nugget
was invented it used to be if you had a
chicken breast you try to give that to
somebody in class or something he's you
busted bro you hand in a big half pound
breast to somebody across the aisle to
school aisle you go on it you go on it
office and you got [ __ ] you know you
got bird on your hands bro you got pole
on your palms papa
but you that's why how the Nugget came
out cuz in case somebody was hungry you
[ __ ] slipped on the Nugget they you
know if it was your little brother you
might [ __ ] spit on it and put it in
his [ __ ] little bottom
you know you hired a nugget and you
but you know writing his own that back
job baby in that but topics Bob let's
hear more which was awesome but then
when we get the bag what happens
following this nugget dog we got five
[ __ ] Nuggets it was so awesome man
and it's just really you know kind of
let life saying hey it's gonna be good
brother so I just want to call and share
that surface at the top hope everything
feel free fire 10k game and wow man
that's cool man you out there yeah you
don't think anybody cares and then
battle mother effer mama not your baby
mother nature handed you that frickin
that bone new baby that bonus nuggets
and you think you you and the wife you
got one for her one for me one for her
one for me and then she thinks y'all all
out you know
and she starts to worry again and just
starts thinking about being at home and
get more of her teeth pulled and just
having to grow more teeth and all the
extra milk she's gonna have to drink and
calcium and all of that and then BAM
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] Valentine's you feel
me a el dia de los Corazon mamacita is
it el dia de los Valentina saying you
get the extra negita um surprise boil
come poquito the surprise knocking mom
god that's beautiful man thank you for
sharing that that's the thing life has
some Sun on the life has that extra plan
for us we can't see my man he took that
do my mother would take me to Wendy's
Brian I remember this because McDonald's
they gave you the [ __ ] it was all this
and that it was yellow paper I didn't
you could kind of see through it you
couldn't look like it might have had
like a carbon or something in it but
dude when you got that Wendy's Burger
and it had a it looked like it was it
from NASA member dad look like a little
astronaut
like who's in here [ __ ] Buzz Aldrin
that's what I'm saying
it was beautiful back then it was
beautiful
back then I'm gonna tell you this if you
like sex David if you like full sex and
some people look some people a lot of
times these days you tell your lady a
goalie in there I'll run in the room
real quick you know blaster baton scoot
out and that's sex that's how because
people are kind of disconnected at times
but some people like full-on old
interactive sex you know touching each
other's bodies and being active and
doing action well blue chew off errs men
a performance enhancement for the
bedroom would you like to last longer
and go extra rounds with your little bad
bambina huh you're a little Malo
mamacita
I wouldn't if I'm doing sex I like to do
one round pretty quickly but at blue to
calm you can get the first chewables
with the same active ingredients as
viagra and Silas so you can get them
dick hitters you feel me cuz I used to
get those in those ones from India from
the Far East and Pakistani little
poppers and you take one of those make
your legs sweat can't even keep a pair
of shorts on where you start getting a
slick my legs you get so sweaty did I
couldn't barely even in my ass cheeks I
couldn't feel them anymore but your
Weiner would be hard up but your Weiner
could spin a ball on its nose it was
just you know God was looking out for
you but it only takes a few minutes to
connect with a blue chewed comm
affiliated physician and if you qualify
you get prescribed online quickly no
in-person doctor visit no awkward
conversation no waiting in line at a
pharmacy this ships directly to your
door ding dong oh it's somebody for my
ding dong you feel me somebody's at the
buzzer for my buzzer it only takes a few
minutes to connect with a blue -
affiliated physician blue - gives you
confidence in bed every time even if you
don't even have anybody at the house
take a couple pills you know what I'm
saying
do something different plank find a
whole new
a plank hands-free you feel me do
something do something wild teach the
cat something you feel me do something
natural blue chill gives you confidence
in bed you and your partner will love it
here's a great deal for you guys visit
blue to calm and get your first order
free when you use promo code th EO just
pay shipping that's B lu e CH e w.com
promo code Theo and that's crazy man
dude I remember when I was young
somebody [ __ ] up at the post office
and they sent us a bunch of plastic wrap
and I don't know how they sent us like a
gross like hundred and forty-four rolls
of plastic wrap like big industrial
Somani [ __ ] up and dude we had a blast
you know we wrapped each other up so
much in that [ __ ] do we do we didn't see
my sister for probably about I bet
almost 40 hours the we SH we wrapped her
in there deep
she couldn't even hear the phone ring
when people would call in the house
that's how far in she was she was in
there and we wrapped her in a rafter a
rafter and she was the L mean it was
hard as a damn golf ball you could you
could knock on it and she was she had a
good sense of humor she'd be in there
like coming I'll be right there and she
would probably three it was probably
three feet from you know we I mean it
was just fascinating so you just never
know what's gonna be we know what's
right around the corner for yourself you
don't know that and I don't know it I
don't know [ __ ] but praise God brother
let's get this little uh let's get this
sound animal right here and let this
little bastard scurry through our
frickin lives hey Theo from thank you
for calling man from Virginia of a tear
in Virginia's second place in the Civil
War let's hear it hurricane coming
through
think about natural disasters in general
and I know you've had some experience
with those but I was thinking that most
natural disasters kind of bring humans
and animals together can you kind of go
through the same experience we get you
know it puts us all on the same level oh
yeah full nature homeward except the
other day though I thought that
earthquakes and birds
you know like birds don't give a [ __ ]
about earthquakes well yeah if earth if
something happens to the earth birds go
on where are they at somewhere else
Jupiter more and that was just kind of
bothering me so I know what your
thoughts are but touch base on that and
get that I like your attitude but we're
out there birds and earthquakes I'm not
shot Birds or sky animals so there's
only a couple animals that can do that
kind of stuff and uh and that's birds so
I'm not surprised that they don't care
about earthquakes now fires they'll get
a little pissed bro because their eggs
will get grilled out and if you came
home and your whole family is suddenly
you know you know what is it called
overeasy then you might get upset you
know if you come home and your whole
family just suddenly covered in a
hollandaise sauce and laying on pieces
of ham you might not feel great you know
what if you come home and your cousin's
over there and you know they got um
hollandaise on his back and he's laying
on a cut of uh hickory smoked I mean
that's how it is for birds if there's a
fire they get more activated because
fire cooks up their ordeal and what is
that call when you have eggs and there's
on a ham and there's like a little
muffin what is that it's beautiful what
is that I love it when I'm at breakfast
I don't get that so
I don't get it a lot I don't get it that
often but every now and I look I read it
though when I see it on the menu I'll be
like mm I'd love to have it but but I'm
not gonna you know it seem like
something you get if you just want a
prize or something oh you then you can
get that but if you're just kind of you
know not winning prizes and just kind of
live in life and just then you know I
feel like you don't get it
and so that's how that's kind of what I
do I get you know I don't get it but I
read it I look around I ask anybody else
if they're gonna get it too I say oh
you're gonna get it mom or you you know
because are you getting that or what boy
look at that beautiful tree and what is
it it's like a little they got a little
ham kind of medallion a little coupled
aliens of pork right there and then they
got that they put an egg on it and god
damn that egg looks like a I mean it
looks like a damn little just a little
tit bra looks like a little protein
titty and they just set it right on
there and then they put a hollandaise on
that thing right I mean in that strong
Holland Oz to like somebody just took
Holland off of a you know like like
somebody just took Holland off of a
globe and just out right onto that
little stack you got going what is that
let me google it real quick the thing is
a damn tasty header bra you put that
thing in your mouth and your [ __ ]
mouth turns into it damn it once more
bra your mouth will start to ovulate you
feel my cheeks Brian hey another angle
dropping I feel something drop into my
throat like damn what was that I'm
getting fallopian in here the [ __ ] has
got me activated you take one bite of
that my pH balance changes I smell like
I've been playing basketball dude that's
how good that tree that breakfast treat
is I think I'm making put on it and it
looks like if you read on the menu like
oh who eats this maybe um someone who's
like a captain in a war or something or
somebody like a woman with like a big
hat you know where somebody that's
crying or something a lot let me see
eggs some sauce meat ham medallion
and it's on a bread sometime it's on a
biscuit or a little and you put it in
like a cut of bread [ __ ] Jesus man
oh sorry that's on you put it on the on
bread egg sauce hammer down on bread
what is it
[ __ ] I misspelled sauce mmm oh this is
it I see a pattern right here what is
this [ __ ]
egg Benedict and that's who it is
egg Benedict man Oh egg Benedict but
he's being nicer now you feel me because
everybody's about to enjoy it you know
Eggs Benedict but uh but it's about to
be you know something everybody can
handle right now
anyway let's get into a little bit more
episode here so that's what I feel about
those animals and the earth I guess here
we go hey Theo was going on gang gang
gang gang brother thank you for calling
man you got a decent voice right there I
like hearing somebody's voice sometimes
cuz a voice is just a handshake that
[ __ ] you know that's in your ears
that's all that is bruh you got me a
tear dude I thought this the other day
my niece was saying what is male and I
said well male I said male you know I
said it's like if I said it's like a
flammable email that's what I told her
and she goes okay but let's hear more
brother home bird listen not about me I
was just wanting to call to just expand
on the thing that you said about how
older people were more physically active
oh yeah we're talking about this last
week about maybe why I get stuck in my
brain sometimes is because my body is
more uh more sedentary more sedate more
calm so of course my brain of course my
mind's gonna run my body ain't running
my mind well something's gonna move you
know I'm built for motion I'm built for
forward onward so if my body isn't being
active that my brain is just gonna run
all the time it really does make sense
let's hear more so that your mental
space yeah they'll have as many dental
problems as young people do now and I
think that's true I'll talk to my dad
a couple weeks ago and he was thought we
were talking about how I'm tired all the
time and all the anxiety and stuff that
I have and you told me that it's because
I'm not physically active like he was
when he was growing up so I am gonna
make an attempt to start working out you
know get off that sugar loser you know
saying yeah man that sugar lizard that's
that easy temptation taking that first
thing let's get that and let's get it oh
that what is that a marshmallow let me
have it huh what is that a Sega Genesis
let me have it huh what is that a little
piece of a cotton candy I'll take that
you know what is it a little roller
skate I'll take it shirt
easy easy easy a titty some ween or some
you know some wiser you know filming
getting the easy hits boy some
pornographer but to really to relax like
what do I really need right now I really
need to do something that's really gonna
benefit me long term all right and just
trying to get healthy and get my mind
where it should be and I do I do agree
when I go like a week and workout I feel
a whole lot better so you know whoever's
here in this is uh eat healthy start
working out and your mind will heal
itself for the most part I mean there
are people out there with with
autoimmune issues and it's very severe
oh mentals they call them and they call
them mentals and some people yet they're
hitchhikers dude their brain is on the
side of the interstate forever they're
never you could where you could tie a
million lassos around them and you'll
still never get them near you
you'll never get them near a decent idea
because they don't have it in them if
you crack them open you find [ __ ]
absolutely nothing right that's mentals
but there's a lot of people that have
different you know uh but there's a lot
of people that are capable
and we're capable man and you can do it
and you can do it man you're not going
to be out there you but yeah we got to
stay active minute just does help us it
does help us man and that's the thing
that I see like a lot of times man I'll
say this like about um you know I think
inspiration where does that you know you
got a heaven some things that inspire
you to stay active but yeah we get
we-we're mind animals we're mind we've
turned into some real mind babies and
and I don't know if it's helping us that
much
that's automation you know we don't have
to do don't have to do as much even
little things they all add up throughout
the day thanks for calling in let me
tell you this here when you're selling
online getting orders out can be a real
pain time-consuming expensive there's so
many carriers to choose from who do you
do use you know UPS um you know everyone
else who cares dude how do you know
you're making the best choice
well ship station is here to help it's
the fastest easiest and most affordable
way to manage and ship your orders ship
station helps we got a new shirt that
we're going to be doing by you belt boys
and it's to be it's going to raise money
for the good fight Foundation which is
Dustin Poirier charity over there and
and so we're gonna sell those shirts as
a dope thing designed by this gentleman
Brian Johnson and it says buy you belt
boys and it's got Dustin with his UFC
strap and it's got it's got me with that
TFA TK guest of the year right there and
so and that's one thing I think that's
just a testament to you know doesn't
inspires people to want to do things
maybe they weren't going to do and it
might be I'm at the gym and I'm thinking
[ __ ] man I don't want to do this but I
think oh man you know paid him full
Dimond up you know so anything inspires
you be like Mike J you know just do it
anything to just get you to through that
over the next little hurdle
or makes you try new things man you know
like raising money you know and doing
something good but anyway shipstation
can help us get those out shipstation
helps you get orders out quickly and
keep your customers happy no matter
where you're selling
that's Amazon Etsy your own website
shipstation brings all your orders into
one simple interface making them really
easy to manage from any device even your
cell phone that simple man do it from
your cell phone it works with all the
major carriers including you USPS FedEx
UPS even Amazon Fulfillment they even
offer big discounts on shipping costs no
wonder shipstation is the number one
choice of online sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
available and right now this past
weekend listeners can try shipstation
for free for 60 days when you use promo
code theo
t-h-e oh there's absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial without even
entering your credit card info just
visit ship station com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in th e oh that ship station
com
then enter promo code theo ship station
comm makes ship happen what else is
going on oh I went and saw the movie
this movie called Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood and I left an hour and 40
minutes in I left out or now in 60 50 60
minutes I think maybe an hour and 65
minutes in or something I left out and I
didn't think it was it was just this
there wasn't there wasn't enough story
for me there wasn't enough and maybe
something's wrong with me but I didn't
like it I thought it was a waste of time
I thought it was a waste of it was too
you know ambidextrous I thought I had
too many hands in the pudding
so you know one thing I thought was
interesting in it watching Brad Pitt
walk usually I haven't seen him walking
a while since I'd held that damn door
for him a few years ago actually on fox
law but watching him walk ins you see
his giddyup he's got a little kind of a
hitch in his giddyup and I thought that
that was just interesting to see that
man walk around he looked a little older
than I remember him looking and that
made me a little sad kind of because
we're all you know we're falling apart
dude that's why maybe everybody maybe
Brad needs to get some fake tits he feel
me
mm-hmm you know I'm saying if you want
to be right get right and uh and what
else did I like about it
Leonardo his character was okay it just
at some point I was definitely locked in
and then some points it was I don't know
because they were acting within acting
so it's like he's acting like two
different characters then you know he's
himself you know he's the character and
then he's the character when he's in the
scenes that the character he's
portraying is playing so I don't know
that [ __ ] just lost me a little I like
some of the old costumes
I wish they'd honestly add a little bit
more sexual in it you know they had some
ladies I went to mind see you know even
a blur eat it I'm saying I don't know
I'll take a picture I'll take a
pixelated titty you know honestly and
maybe I'm just getting you know keyed up
because it's winter and and people you
know it's winter you start thinking
about sex really because you want to
survive and if you don't survive you
want something to survive so you want to
seed out you want to see it out and get
a woman but you know bellied up so you
can something else can live actually
that's a question that came in here
patreon from cigars ah JH a Theo as we
approach fall do you feel like people's
moods change in anticipation for winter
I live in the Midwest and I can
definitely notice it curious of your
perspective on the west coast
yeah I think it does I like it you know
we don't get it here here there's
nothing this there's no do we got our
advisory in our cars now that comes
through if you get if there's gonna be
wind I've got a wind advisory in
California yesterday do you know how
much wind there was that much dude no
nothing literally I think two old women
had sneezed at the same time over in Van
Nuys and they call the wind advisory
people are nervous people are crying
somebody sue people are trying to sue
the clouds I mean it's just so we don't
get any weather in California so we
don't know but when I remember really
the joys of my time and being in places
where that where the fall comes in and
autumn yeah that makes me feel nice to
walk outside and feel the bluster just
feel mother nature's it's like a cold
crisp breeze just sneak up your skirt
kind of touch your [ __ ] vulva little
you feel me or touch your nuts if you
have real small nuts and Mother Nature
thinks you have you know that you might
have a vagina there's something magical
about that about autumn about went you
know because autumn is winters little
dirty little sneaky little trampy little
brother and he's you know just thought
and around is chewing gum and just
getting into anybody's car even if it's
not an uber just any strong man that's
driving around autumn will jump in the
backseat and just say Oh drive me oh
yeah I'm going I'll go somewhere where
you go and hey my name is Troy my name
is Tony you know my name is Ari my name
is I you know a wiedersehen baby so a
lot of men out there being wild and [ __ ]
what are we talking about dude what the
[ __ ] are we even talking about my [ __ ]
is give him wild Oh
anticipation for winter yes you see a
lot of people anticipating winter and I
wish the calendars were trickier a lot
of calendars
let you know immediately oh it's you
know oh yeah September winners coming
you know September October I wish they
had to you know they mixed it up you
know you're out at the beach you know
you got three nights at the beach but
the third night is uh or the second
night is the second night is like um the
first of the next month and bam you
don't even know it you wake up in the
morning and they got [ __ ] 40 inches
of snow out there on top of your
sandcastle and little Benjamin's out
there [ __ ] boogie boardin in 60 feet
of frozen waves so that's I wish mother
nature had a little more trickery in her
bag but it could happen you never know
and that's the thing about mom I'm not
sure that [ __ ] is legit ah so that's
how I feel about that
Marisa Bruno do you have any tattoos or
do you want any opinions on tattoos I
like tattoos I like a pale woman with
some tats on us what I like to see make
my dick real fancy make my dick feel
like thinking about something you know
or make my body erect get my you know
make my blood just started looking for
the end of my wiener and that's how I
feel about tattoos man to make boy and
my nuts will get hard I'm at that age
where my nuts get hard as well still I'm
fired up dude when I was young if I got
erect my whole body
they couldn't even do anything I
couldn't move for probably four hours if
I got real hard and out everything man I
was hard as hell even my tongue yeah
when you young and you got that virality
that erection boy all your blood trying
to get out of your body at once but
through places through unique areas bro
your butt your all your blood is just
cold a second in you know in your Weiner
skin my heavens that was a wild time
being young due to my nuts would get
erect and hard that you could you could
knock on my nuts bruh
and nobody would answer dude because
there's no that's not a door as nuts
babe
yeah and that's how my body was dude I
you know I would get it all just so hard
but I would you know if I was getting
erect if I noticed it coming on I put
one of my hands up like this so I be at
least kind of hardened in like a waving
position dude they some I just get like
this they'd put me in the yard and birds
would land on me be like dang is he a
scarecrow Birds stopping by be like man
I know that boy's just feeling the fires
of his loins and boys got a six along
fire near as down near his ass boy and
his nuts and and in his route but what
was the question
tattoos anyway uh all right let's take
another call I know we got a lot of
hands today man I'm grateful for it
you know grateful for it I got a
question for you which of my online
searches does the government have a
right to know about do you think it's
how how long can this uncook bacons sit
in my frigerator do you think it's what
is the word discursion me or do you
think it's um
oh uh how deep are my the answer none of
the above if you have expressvpn
without express VPNs protection though
hackers government's ad companies and
ISPs all have full access to your data
that's right I don't want them using my
web history or video searches against me
actually I'd love to see him play some
of those video searches in a court of
law
boy everybody in there it would really
be thinking about sex probably but
that's why I use expressvpn every time I
go online expressvpn encrypts and
reroute to your web traffic to any
number of countries keeping you safer
and secure simply download the
expressvpn app click to connect and boom
you're protected expressvpn is the
fastest VPN I've tried and it costs less
than seven dollars per month and comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
protect your online activity today and
find out how you can get three months
free at expressvpn comm slash th EO
that's exp ress VPN dot c om / th EO for
three months free with a one-year
package it protect yourself protect your
search history visit expressvpn comm
slash Theo to learn more let's take
another call right here here we go
Francisco from New Jersey
what's up Francisco thank you for
calling and I'll let you know this week
if those um those Salyersville shows are
gonna be back on the map or what's going
to happen I'll let you guys know on
social media
we're issue that recently just you know
happened to me recently you know it was
what a girl you know we were you know we
would like hanging out for you know
about like to Nast month you know I
thought he was going pretty good and
then all of a sudden that she liked
basically just cut me off you know
without any rhyme or reason and just you
know just left it okay so you guys
everything was real tidy and then uh
suddenly everything was unkempt and she
just disappeared on you I hope she's
okay
I hope somebody you know that she's
gonna be okay wherever so you know
whatever's going on let's hear more
about this maybe some clues but in a way
it affected me so deeply that you know
it kind of inspired me to you know
relook like look at myself and you know
really started digging in deep and
understanding the things that I like to
do so I've been like you know I'm going
deeper into my art and drawing and
painting and whatnot but I just want to
know like if have you ever had a woman
that even if she was in your life for so
it's like it's for such a short time or
just anybody have they affected you too
really just get make you get lost and to
do what you love to do and be a better
version of yourself but stay up man get
in Gang Gang Gang bruh nope I've never
had that type of woman in my life where
when they left me that I decided to
delve into myself and get to know myself
about better what that's called is a
adult move brother that's what you're
doing right now you're doing adult moves
dude I remember some girl left me dude I
barely even [ __ ] knew her and I'm
just next thing you know I'm you know I
hitchhiked over there to Charleston and
I'm petting a cat on a porch and you
know I just hope you know you know
hoping she lived there and she even
owned a cat somebody else's cat you know
but so I could have went to jail dude
and this was this is back when you know
that was a pretty decent crime now
that's nothing bro I mean now that's
[ __ ] flirtin these days but yeah dude
no I remember some girl I mean dude my
life if a woman rejected me man that I
thought cared about me dude it hurt me
it hit me so hard when I was young did
it hit me so hard [ __ ] cuz I just you
know I didn't have the the you know they
just it um you know these these [ __ ]
boy know these a woman you know I just I
had never had a good connection with the
woman out always I put women on such a
pedestal that uh then I think I couldn't
believe they were even communicating
with me so in one would and then would
stop or it was a girlfriend or something
have to be a girlfriend a girl I cared
about man it just there was nothing left
to me you know it just reinforced all
these weird ideas or connections that I
had with women where I just you know I
think it went back to being a child and
just uh you know my brother touched on
it a little bit just that um you know
you have to find a way I guess to
connect with your children if possible
unless they're supposed to be killers or
something or serial killers but you know
in my I think I just didn't get that
when I was young I didn't get that
connection so when I would match up with
a girl I I felt like she was a all my
affection for a a mother immediately
latched on to her once a girl loved me
or you know expressed that to me man I I
treated them like a mother and I didn't
do it on purpose you know I was still
doing with sex and doing tits and all of
that and doing that
you know when one girl do you know
masturbating me often in the water over
there but um you know over they're about
to move about kind of over by the movie
theater but um but we talked about - oh
but yeah I had this motherly issue where
I would make him my mom and my heart
somewhere my heart would make a girl
that I just cared about my mom and so
when they left me it felt like like my
own mother was leaving me and so it just
hit me I was just shattered so no dude I
would [ __ ] lay in the back and do a
Newports brah I remember even putting
dark kind of stuff on my body wanting to
be a black guy one time I was doing that
you know I just wanted to not be myself
I'm smoking Newports through my nose bro
like a [ __ ] straight dragon bro like
a Detroit dragon so I remember getting
into the dark arts and I mean [ __ ]
just letting Voldemort just just drive a
[ __ ] motorcycle up and down my
[ __ ] brain waves I would be broke
dude I would be shattered dude this one
girl thought she knew French so I
[ __ ] learned a bunch of French and go
talk to her she don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about so if you don't think
that I don't know what's going on
then you could be right so it's
everything you know it's everything
but um but yeah dude it's uh yeah that's
oh I wasn't good at it so you hearing
you talk right now
makes me wish I was you man makes me
wish I had that foresight to see the
awareness to see the bigger picture that
you're getting a ticket some time to get
to know yourself bro let me give you
that they call me [ __ ] Bobby two
hands baby let me give you that round of
ap right there son and that's not adult
penis that's a plaus because you deserve
it
um Wow I don't even know what we talked
about today but happy birthday anybody's
birthday's been or coming up you know I
think we have a lot of things to be
grateful for in our lives I mean I
really do and I'm glad that I'm feeling
that way today and I'm glad that I'm
able to feel that way because there's
times when I don't and it's hard it's
hard to feel comfortable in the world if
I'm not feeling any gratitude so yeah I
don't know but I appreciate you guys
getting involved and paying attention
and being a part of uh of this past
weekend and and I'm grateful grateful
for you guys what else what else what
else we got it we did it we made it
through it
we're cruising you got a beautiful week
ahead of you
football's back you know they probably
maybe maybe a new girl gonna move into
town this week you don't know
let's keep open for the opportunities
that could be out there waiting for us
you know we're probably good people you
know there's be it sometimes we're in a
tough moment where like I don't know if
this is the right thing what is gonna
what's gonna happen now I bet something
special is that's what I bet you know
what I'm gonna try to put my money on
that right now
that something special is gonna happen I
think it could I think it could let's
get out of here on the horse that we
rode in on
and that is a bishop gun anything you
want
and you guys be good to yourselves out
there and uh and I'm gonna try it too
and we you know I bet if we look into
our lives we got something to be
grateful for you know we got a lot of
things and we're here this is our
opportunity and I bet we're part of
something bigger that we can't even see
sometimes it's hard it's hard sometimes
to have that faith you know to just be
like oh man I don't know what is going
on right now and it doesn't feel right
and it doesn't and it's not what I
expected and man I'm going through some
of that in my life and and it's hard to
just say to the universe or say to your
higher power to say look I'm just gonna
believe that this is what I'm just going
to accept what is I'm just gonna believe
that this is that the next curve is man
it's gonna head to a beautiful loaf you
know a little thoroughfare you feel me I
feel like we're all headed towards a
beautiful little thoroughfare so you
guys be good to yourself you deserve it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
since with another man's fantasy
and nouns
the approach to a paper anonymity
that's right a home to God
[Music]
you can
[Music]
we're the bright light
[Music]
black two you're getting ready for the
next in line
[Music]
[Music]